it just felt so good and like like home
it felt like home and you know our sense
of humor is the same we laugh the same
we just
see things the same there's a history
there there's an effortlessness there we
got in the way
of each other it will always be you and
i
nearly one year after marissa hargitay
and christopher maloney reunited on
screen for law order organized crime the
two cannot stop gushing about working
together again of course they famously
shared the screen on law order svu from
1999 to 2011. isn't that our job
protecting serving you know if there are
eight million of us who could protect
everyone in the city then everyone will
be able to sleep at night are you gonna
sleep tonight elliott you know when
chris um left
i knew he would be back i don't think he
did i know he didn't but i did so it was
very exciting for him to come back and
to come back in such a beautiful way i
think we get to
play notes that only she and i can play
together the whatever that
you know what comes out of that duet for
me
and our character specifically because
it's like the second we got together
zero time had passed magic didn't miss a
step and it just felt so good and like
like home it felt like home it's
very unique and so that is refreshing
and i think gives life to both of us so
it was a beautiful gift and it was very
invigorating for me and
for him and i'm just so proud of him to
be gone for 10 years and just to be so
culturally relevant now
and that welcomed back because he's that
good and that's special stenson fans
were not disappointed when maloney's
character was reintroduced last year for
his spin-off series organized crime and
their renewed chemistry is spilling off
screen too check out their rock solid
friendship on full display united hand
in hand at the law order revival
premiere it's just been a joy it's been
a joy another famous face making a
return to the ellen doe franchise sam
waterston the suspended disbelief a long
while ago the sets are the same the show
it's very much the same story structure
and all that when you asked me to come
here you said i need someone with the
guts to make hard decisions i still feel
that way and the law order family is
freaking out it is so exciting and i
just about fell over when i saw
sam waterston because he's
so gorgeous and vibrant he's just such
an incredible force to be reckoned with
so distinguished so talented so many
things he was iconic then not to mention
now
but um
and so beautiful and so playful and so
unique and talented and irreplaceable
and it's very exciting to see somebody
coming back with such a splash as more
crossover rumors are making the rounds
could waterson's character cross over i
don't know i've been hearing a lot about
it why not as for maloney and hargitay
well they're certainly on board oh god
yes dick has already told me that we're
going to so it's just a matter of time
which i'm so very excited about i'm
excited about the night that it's a
three show crossover
which
sounds impossible but we can do it that
was actually one of my first thoughts
when i heard it was coming up down the
pike and i was like well i gotta i
better cheat into the front of the line
to see if we can make that happen
[Music]